i've been to see the prime minister to
resign
as secretary of state for health and
social care
i understand the enormous sacrifices
that
everybody in this country has made that
you have made
and those of us who make these rules
have got to stick by them and that's why
i've got to resign
i want to thank people for their
incredible
sacrifices and what they've done
everybody working in the nhs across
social care everyone involved in the in
the vaccine
program and frankly everybody in this
country
who has risen to the challenges that
we've seen
over this past 18 months i'm very proud
of what we've done
to protect the nhs at the peak to
deliver that vaccine rollout for one of
the fastest in the world
and i look forward to supporting
the government and the prime minister
from the back benches
to make sure that we can get out of this
pandemic
we're so close to the end and then
build back better so that this country
can fulfill
its potential which is so great
and i will do that with all of my heart